sounds being interviewed saliz's we're
thing I call it he goes into stockbroker
mode so I'll just starts talking he
sound hits that term because his wife
agrees with me
yeah then goes into this weird zone yeah
where he just starts saying words and
they don't mean anything and then the
key ingredient is in sincerity yeah so
Sal's gonna talk about how its
positivity and how he loves horses but
why am i insincere why yes you well
listen to yourself all right let's hear
the clip here we go guys well if you
don't know who saw the turtle is the
two-legged version is right here govern
Ally from that Howard Stern Show
I mean I've talked to you before but
Geoff Blum named this horse after you
and he's the favorite years that because
you're here Sal the turtle is the
favorite I mean I can't believe for once
in my life I'm at a loss of words I mean
my horse is the favorite thanks to Jeff
bloom and bloom stables I'm so excited
you know what I think it is I think it's
like just like the power of positivity
it's just the vibes and the goodness
some people bet on names some people bet
on numbers we bet on love and sow the
turtle is all about love he's got a lot
of spirit he has a lot of heart he is
what I considered to be our modern-day
Seabiscuit you know oh that's a lofty
comparison I'd say I just saw the movie
yesterday I just catch it up on my her
horse stuff you know my horse history I
know a little bit about Secretariat then
the Seabiscuit and I'm thinking oh god
there's gonna be sow the turtle Gary he
just he just talks for the sake of
talking right he just he what did he
even say that he's Robin what did he say
I don't know you feel you have to fill
up time no I'll tell you oh you're a
professional bull [ __ ] there's a
problems Howard Gary you pulled the lame
clip no the right clip you embarrassed
the show was a stand now I did it it was
a standard interview why is it these
other shows
this is the only sure way you could be
positive and you're still a [ __ ] at
these vamps for 20 seconds in the
beginning of that [ __ ] yeah and then
he sorta comes up with the positivity
role not even think he knows what the
question I mean do you really love
horses as much as you say in that clip
yeah I do I grew up with horses I mean
you grew up with horses oh no my dad
used to take me to the OTB generate
gamblers